did everyone see Game of Thrones yes how
do you feel can we talk about spoilers
in this I think so
[ __ ] yeah if you haven't already watched
it turn it off now let me say this is
the greatest television show ever made
is what I want to say that's my opinion
my brother Steve was reluctant you know
what he said to me last night
what he's caught up now yeah Oh caught
up cut up cut up cut up yeah and he goes
I don't want her ever to go away I want
them to keep shooting it why can't they
keep shooting it I did I I need it I
need about maybe two more seasons max I
need some closure in my life I don't
need new characters to sprout up season
the last season right no more more I
need it to round out immortality I think
there's two more seasons after this one
correct oh thank god okay good I thought
it was just okay yeah because there's
still too many home ports there's too
many still trying to stay claim to
things I think by the last season and I
think it's probably gonna narrow down to
four or three major ports so next Sunday
it's going to be the battle between
Ramsay the Bolton's argh star Carson Jon
Jon and Sansa and Arya is coming back
from wherever she is to go home to
Winterfell all the Starks it's dark so
hopefully there's a reunion there and
who the [ __ ] is Lady Stoneheart
George wait we can't reveal this because
isn't that not only is that a spoiler
alerts but that's an actual book a
spoiler whoopsies well we have anyway I
just did it okay so for people who don't
care to know the possibilities of what
might happen to the game if you're if
you're really dead set on not hearing
any spoilers at all turn it off now but
yes there's a possibility according to
Bobby that cat stark comes back to life
right I read that mm-hmm is in the books
right it says that she comes back to
life and she's Lady Stoneheart and she's
also not the same
right she's a cold-hearted she's killer
no she's also right demonic or something
or not demonic but she has from the
photos I looked at from the cartoon like
people drew her own pictures of Lady
Stoneheart she looks very demonic yeah
you know but um
she's you know if she has powers I don't
know I mean if she's half dead would she
have like half white Walker powers
because I've I wondered that about Jon
Snow to when he was resurrected from the
dead I thought to myself is he the same
person or is he gonna have you know
certain powers because he has visited
the other end the other side I think
something's gonna happen during the
battle is grab Dula he's gonna freak out
and something happens like he shoots out
snow or yeah Jon Snow yeah he's gonna be
like I can't do this my goal Super
Saiyan and all oh my god Super Saiyan if
you super safe that's it with blue hair
yeah melt the ice around him game over
yeah I'd like that very much
but it's gonna be amazing I think I
think that I'm gonna I'm gonna find more
pleasure in the death of Ramsay Bolton
than I will the death of Joffrey
I absolutely a bore to the deepest core
of me I hate Ramsay Bolton so much and
and I think that yeah when Joffrey I
would say I say oh my lord I hate him
cuz I was young dumb my number one was
Ollie yeah because I thought that
conditioned I thought that too until
they hung him and I realized wow he was
just a kid he was just a kid who was who
didn't know where he stood so he wanted
to like show some loyalty to the wrong
people and he but when he when they hung
him my heart I just felt awful about
hating him how does this make you feel
for the Nights Watch yeah yeah traitor
he traitors give you traitor
the Lord Commander hey what's the deal
with the queen of dragons who do you
make your predictions now like a fight
who do you think is sitting on the
throne at the end of everything
wins the game pick your person I think
it's gonna be uh Santa I don't think
it's gonna be song son Jon Snow
oh is it starts so you so are you as
part of that mix too
and you don't think Turnham taught him
what his name I think Oh Tom Tom problem
no I think that bran oh but he's a star
because I think he's a warg and if a
warg can find his way into the head of
the dragon then he can control the
Dragons mm-hmm right yeah
so you think Denarius is done I think no
no I think that maybe there's a myth
there could be a pact between the Starks
and the Daenerys there's reports in the
beginning it was the Lannisters running
everything everything in Winterfell was
the Starks right yeah you can still
split up in that way or whatever but um
I'm just more concerned about Cersei and
just specific people I know what do you
mean worried about her I just wanted why
do you why do you want her to succeed
she's she's she's a villainous woman I
like the only the only redeeming trait
about her is that she loves her children
that's it
I know that she made by [ __ ] her
brother well you know that's like incest
is wrong unless your brother looks like
Jaime Lannister at suck it mom if your
sister was Thursday you'd [ __ ] her yeah
Cersei with the haircut now with the
Rachel Maddow now yeah I would walk like
a Cersei would have half Korean kids if
I was the guy I was her brother he just
liked the idea of her happy half Korean
did have sex with Cersei he took a
turkey baster waited till she went to
sleep and just squirted her sperm in
there right does that work yeah yeah
well this is a sperm die in die in the
die turkey baster
I think that you can turkey base the
pregnancy uh-huh there there you know
there are weirder ways to get pregnant I
think turkey basting is pretty standards
top
[Music]